hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the brand new Sony vlogging
camera this is the zv1 Mark II now this
does look incredibly similar to their
previous dv1 but it has some amazing
upgrades it now has an even wider angle
lens it's an 18 to 50. it has cinematic
Vlog settings an AI microphone touch
screen USBC and a built-in ND filter
which is I'm not gonna lie probably one
of my favorite features out of
everything there's also a bunch of
little other upgrades like closer Focus
active mode creative looks upgraded snq
self timer shot Mark step zoom and even
connects with the Sony creators app
there is so much packed inside of this
little camera it's pretty overwhelming
so first things this ND filter which is
built in and I'm so excited about this
because I do a ton of filming outside so
as you can see this shot is very
Overexposed it's super bright luckily we
have a built-in ND filter so we can turn
that on right now and what's cool about
this is you don't actually have to turn
the camera camera off and it's super
easy because what you do have to do
normally this is the camera that we've
been filming with outside and I have to
actually screw this off if I don't want
the ND filter and if I want it on I have
to screw it back on but with this
it's just the Press of a button it's
incredible the new cinematic Vlog
setting will give you a wide aspect
ratio and it'll automatically switch
your settings to 24 frames a second and
it lets you choose from various looks
and modes cinematic Vlog 24 frames a
second we've got these black bars to
make it just look even more
theatrical there's a bunch of different
ones so it's really fun to kind of play
around find your look and see what you
like the best the face Priority auto
exposure is something that I absolutely
love in these cameras it keeps the
brightness of your face consistent even
in different types of lighting
conditions it's pretty well lit because
it's kind of overcast but now when I
walk into this dark parking garage and
now all the light is behind me this will
automatically adjust so that my face
will stay lit and bright and it'll
automatically expose everything
foreign
it can be really bright in one second
and then the next you step into shade
but with this it's able to automatically
adjust on the Fly depending upon what
those lighting conditions are creative
looks let you choose from these 10
different presets and there's eight
different settings inside of those to
change up the look of your videos very
quickly and easily there's also another
option called my image style that lets
you change the brightness color and look
to whatever you want I like this because
it quickly will let you make some subtle
adjustments if you need to now this new
microphone is something that they
released in the zde1 camera and I
already did review that camera so if you
want to check out that video be sure to
go watch it after you watch this one but
what makes this so powerful is how it
uses AI to determine where it should be
recording if I'm out filming and I'm
talking behind the camera it will
automatically focus more on my voice but
if a person steps in front it may start
recording the audio from the front
instead of the back you can manually
choose where it records if you want and
that's super easy to switch right here
in the settings this windscreen is a
nice little addition that helps block
out unwanted sounds from the wind I like
to call this the
so go ahead just try to change my mind
by calling it anything else it's not
going to happen if you want to add an
external microphone there is a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack and it has the
multi-interface shoe that works with
various Sony microphones image
stabilization is something that is
always very important for me on these
types of cameras with active mode
enabled you'll be able to notice a
pretty big difference in how stable the
footage is also if you want to really
dive in and get more stabilization you
can use Sony's plugin that uses the
metadata captured while you're filming
to really get even more of a smoother
shot snq that stands for slow and quick
on the top here you have a dedicated
button to choose from photo video or snq
I love using this for time lapses and
getting quick slow motion b-roll shots
now for those Pros who want more control
on coloring you can shoot an s-log 3 and
they even have proxy recording so I
don't usually shoot with proxy but this
is great for those who do use proxy
footage this can actually save you a lot
of time rather than having to create
them and post later this has the
recording lamp light right here and this
red box around the frame is like this
added extra bonus of like hello yes you
are actually recording I really wish
that they had this on some of their pro
model cameras and even if you think that
you're a pro and you'll never forget to
hit record there are definitely those
times where I have forgot and you don't
ever realize it until it's too late now
some settings that I really like in
these cameras is the background defocus
this will quickly blur out your
background and adjust the aperture for
use so you will have that beautiful
blurred out look and all of that happens
at the Press of a button this also has
product showcase which isn't a new
feature but it is worth mentioning
because it works so freaking well my
product showcase turned on and we're
gonna try out these little almond bites
so
Now You See Me now you see the Almond
bites
gonna focus on them almond bite
um you just switched to this mode and
whenever you hold something up in front
of it it will quickly adjust to focus on
that instead of your face they also have
this skin smoothing feature now this has
a low medium and a high and you can also
decide to turn this off I like to keep
it at the low if not off because
sometimes when you have it set to the
High version I mean you begin to not
even look like a person like it is
almost too smooth and too perfect that
you're like something's up is it a
filter and you'll be like hashtag no
filter and then we're like no yeah
there's a filter so keeping it on the
low end just like this works pretty well
for me and I think if you want to use
this feature the low setting it's
perfect now I mostly use these cameras
for video and I honestly completely
forget that they actually take photos as
well this has a 20 megapixel sensor with
super fast autofocus speeds and it will
actually let you shoot 24 frames a
second of raw or jpeg up to about a
thousand frames and be completely
blackout free which is pretty impressive
in such a small little camera another
thing that these are great for is using
them as a webcam or a live streaming
device it will only let you output up to
720 but honestly for most calls or
streams it's gonna look pretty great so
my friends that's a first look at the
new zv1 Mark II camera I will put a link
in the description if you want to get
more information maybe maybe I'll make
you guys a special little zv1 Mark II
Vlog they're naming conventions on their
cameras like I I just won't even go into
it